Steve Dalkowski was a minor league
pitcher with a fabled fastball the model
for nuke LaLoosh Tim Robbins wild
throwing character in Bulldog barbering
8 in the minor leagues dal Kowski set
strikeout records every where he played
in the 60s but as dal Kowski himself
admitted there was a problem he walked
as many batters as he struck out and
would never play in the majors in the
words of Bull Durham director ron
shelton he had the equivalent of
michelangelo's gift but could never
finish a painting Steve Dalkowski was 80
doctor de Luther King and his wife Louis
were inseparable for 60 years Louis and
D as he was known met in Chicago in 1960
she was a dental hygienist he a resident
at Howard University School of Medicine
going into the field of medicine my
concern was to be of service in Alabama
dr. King became the first black doctor
at the Tuskegee VA hospital later he'd
set up a thriving practice in Atlanta
they were very much in love said their
son Ron loving on April 10th just hours
after he buried his father loving got
the call his mother had died too dr. de
Luther King jr. and Lois King were both
96
Madhvi aya was a physician's assistant
who worked the emergency room at
Brooklyn's Woodhull Medical Center she'd
been a doctor in India before moving to
the u.s. in 1994 to join her husband Raj
and to raise their daughter Manoli
there's nothing everything about Curtis
made me feel like that was safe and then
I was a whole
Manoli a college freshman texted her mom
while she was in the hospital in a few
days after her passing I kept texting
her wanting to believe that it wasn't
true that she passed away I miss you she
wrote thank you for coming to me in my
dreams
Madhvi aya was 61 jose Fontana's was the
first boston police officer to die of co
fit 19
we lost the hero today to this virus
mayor Marty Walsh paid tribute to the 29
year veteran of the force Fontana's
spent 24 of them have the same Jamaica
Plain station he was a great soul said
his old friend detective David Martinez
who called him beaky he treated people
with kindness respect love and that
carried through to his family Fontana's
law enforcement family escorted his
casket to the cemetery jose Fontana's
was 53 Raymond Copeland was a sanitation
worker in New York City a single father
he raised three daughters after their
mother died he took three jobs at one
point to be able to provide for us said
his oldest daughter
Naima Saifullah Copeland joined the
Sanitation Department in 2015 and met
Tamika Robinson on the job last year
they were engaged he was kind and
generous she said and treated me like a
queen Raymond Copeland was 46
Samantha wissen jur was a registered
nurse in Michigan who'd worked at
Beaumont Hospital anything you asked she
do it said Sam Bachman her best friend
of more than 20 years she was a warrior
Samantha fought through stage three
breast cancer and sage for brain cancer
she found the love of her life online
and last year married Marcus Wis injure
in Nashville next month would have been
their first anniversary
Samantha Whistler was 29
[Music]
you